MIKE COLEMAN: Hi I'm Mike
Coleman, a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud.
In this video, I
want to walk you
through how you can use Google
Cloud's Migrate for Anthos
to move some of your
existing Windows workloads
from virtual machines to
containers in just a few steps.
This video builds
on an earlier one,
introducing Migrate for Anthos.
If you haven't checked
that video out yet,
definitely go do so,
as this one assumes
you performed the prerequisites
we outlined there.
At the end of the last video,
we had set up our service
accounts, enabled
the necessary APIs,
and created a
processing cluster.
Before we can do the
actual migration,
we need to complete a couple of
Windows-specific prerequisites.
We need to add a Windows node
pool to our processing cluster,
and ensure we have
a Windows Build VM.
We need the node pool
to ensure that we can
analyze Windows applications.
And unlike with
Linux applications,
there isn't an
automated container
build step with Windows apps.
Migrate for Anthos will
create a Docker file,
but you will need
a VM on which you
can do the actual
Docker build as well
as push the resulting image
up to the Google Container
Registry.
So let's set both of those up.
I've logged into the
Google Cloud console,
and I'm ready to get started.
So I'll click on
Processing Cluster.
I'll go ahead and
add the node pool.
We're going to go with one node.
So let's click that there.
Come over here, we're
going to change this
to the Windows semiannual
channel release,
so we'll click Make Changes.
I want to come down
here and I want
to use an N 1 standard 4 as
my machine for the node pool,
and we'll come down,
and then for security, I
want to make sure that I
have full platform access,
and we'll click that, and
then we'll click Create.
And that will add the node pool.
So next thing I
want to do is I want
to add the machine that I'll
use to build my Docker images.
So we're going to
come up over here,
and we're going to click on
Compute Engine, Virtual Machine
Instances, we'll
do Create Instance.
We'll call the
machine Win Build 1.
We're going to put it in
the US West 2A region,
we're going to use
an N 1 standard 4,
and we'll use Windows Server
1909 Data Center Edition.
We want to come down here and
ensure we have full platform
scope again, and
we'll click Create,
and that will go off and
create our build machine.
With those additional
prerequisites set up,
let's jump into using
Migrate for Anthos
to migrate a
Windows application.
As a brief recap,
Migrate for Anthos
has three primary components.
The first is the
discovery tool, which
assesses how successful
a migration of a given
application might be.
Next is the processing
cluster, a kubernetes cluster
that is used to
examine the source VM
and create the migration
plan, as well as execute
the actual migration.
And finally, migctl,
a command line tool,
like kube ctl, for interacting
with the processing cluster.
We'll do most of our work
in the console today,
but I will show you
a bit of migctl.
And again, to quickly
recap, a migration
generally consists of
the following steps.
Creating a Google Cloud project,
setting up service accounts,
and enabling the
appropriate APIs,
creating migration processing
cluster and a build
VM in the case of Windows,
choosing and qualifying
your workload, defining
your migration source,
creating a migration plan, and
adjusting the migration plan
to ensure it meets your
needs, creating the deployment
artifacts, and deploying
the newly containerised
application.
We now have the first two items.
So let's jump into how you can
choose the right application.
The first thing to
consider is which
operating systems IIS and dot
NET versions can be migrated.
We migrate Microsoft
Windows Server 2008
R2 or higher, Microsoft IIS
7, or higher web applications,
and ASP.NET and dot
NET framework versions
3.5 or higher.
It's important to note
that after Migration,
the resulting container will
run Windows Server version 1909.
In addition to specific versions
of the operating system or app
stack, the following
application characteristics
make them unsuitable
for migration.
Applications with
dependencies on GPUs or TPUs,
applications with low level
networking requirements,
desktop, RDP, and
VDI applications,
and applications with
bring your own licensing.
In order to help determine if
an application is a good fit,
we have the Application
Discovery Tool.
The tool outputs a zip file
that indicates whether or not
the Windows VM is a
potential fit for Migration.
The name of the file
indicates the results.
The zip file includes
multiple files
with information on the
operating system settings, IIS,
odbc config, and the
global assembly cache.
I'm not going to go into the
zip file contents in depth,
and would encourage you
to check out the docs
if you need more information.
Let's take a look at the
Migration tool in action.
But before we do that,
I want to give you
an overview of the application
we'll be migrating.
This is a simple
ASP.NET application.
It's got this
webfront end running
on IIS that connects back
to a Cloud SQL instance.
So if I click on
Courses, you can
see a bunch of courses come up.
Those are being pulled out
of the Cloud SQL database.
The virtual machine
is right here.
It's called Cymbal
University, and that's
what we're going to migrate.
I've already set up an
RDP session into that box,
so we'll move into
that now, and I've
installed the Migrate for
Anthos migration tool.
You can see it right here,
collect info dot exe.
So I'll hit Enter, and
we'll run that tool.
It's going to go
through, it's going
to collect a bunch of
system information.
That's going to
take a little bit,
so I'm going to fast
forward the video,
and I'll rejoin you in a second.
So the tool is finished, and if
we look at the file name here,
it doesn't say no
fit, which means
we actually do have a fit.
So our application
is good to go,
and should be an easy migration.
We have completed
our prerequisites,
and our application
is a good fit.
So at this point, we're
ready to go ahead and create
our migration source.
Before we start creating
actual migration,
I just wanted to review
a couple of points.
First, a Windows
instance can only
be migrated from a
Compute Engine instance.
So that's what we've
got going on here.
We've got Cymbal University
on a Compute Engine VM.
The second thing is, you cannot
migrate a VM until you stop it.
So I'm going to come over
here to Cymbal University,
I'm going to select it, and
I'm going to click Stop.
With the VM stopped,
I can now go
to Migrate to Containers
here in the menu,
and start the migration process.
We added our processing
cluster earlier, so here it is.
It's in the UI.
Now we're going to add
a migration source.
So I'm going to
click Add Source,
I'm going to select that
processing cluster, click Next,
give it a name.
Windows Migration Source.
It's going to come
off Compute Engine.
Click Next.
And now, we're going to
create a service account.
So we can have this done
automatically for us.
The service account is going to
have the viewer and the storage
admin roles assigned to it.
So we'll go ahead
and click Next.
And Add Source, and that will
add our migration source.
The source is now ready.
It can handle Windows
and Linux workloads.
So let's create the
actual migration.
Click Create Migration,
come in here,
give the migration a name.
We'll call it Windows Migration.
Select the source that we just
created from the dropdown,
select the operating
system as Windows,
and then type in the name
of the virtual machine
that we're going to migrate,
which was Cymbal University.
We'll come down here and
we'll click Create Migration.
That's going to start the
creation of the migration plan,
and that's going to
take a few seconds.
So let me go ahead and
fast forward the video,
and I'll rejoin you
when that's done.
OK, the migration plan
has been generated.
And the next step here
would be to review and edit
that migration plan.
So we come in and we
take a look at it.
We're not actually
going to edit it.
We're not going to spend
a lot of time here.
I'll just point out
some highlights.
You can see here we're
running a dot NET 4 5
classic application,
here's the web
route directory, information
like that, port 80.
So all of that looks good.
So let's go ahead and save that
and generate our artifacts.
Now, this is going to go out
and create our Docker file.
Again, this is going to
take a couple seconds,
so I'm going to go ahead
and pause the video,
and I'll rejoin you
when it's finished.
The artifacts have
been generated,
and those are actually stored in
a Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And there's a couple different
ways you could get at them.
You could go to the
bucket directly,
or you can actually use migctl
to give you the location,
and then copy the file down.
And that's what
we're going to do.
So I'm going to open
up a Cloud Shell,
and I'm going to issue that
migctl Get Artifacts command,
and point at the
migration we just did,
and that's going to give me
the command that I need to run.
So I'm going to copy
that command, gs util cp,
gs util copy, and we're going
to run that in our Windows
build machine where we're going
to build our Docker image.
So let's run that copy
command, and that's
going to bring down
the artifacts dot zip
file, so it's been copied.
Let's look at the directory
and make sure it's there.
Clear the screen,
and we'll do a DIR,
and there's our artifacts file.
So let's expand that archive
to get to the Docker file.
So Expand Archive,
artifacts dot zip,
hit Enter, archive
will get expanded out,
and we will have
our Docker file.
All right, let's
clear the screen.
Let's take a look at
that artifacts directory
to make sure we got
our Docker file.
So do the directory, and
there's the Docker file.
So now let's issue our
Docker build command,
and tag it so it can be pushed
up to Google Container Registry
after the build is finished.
So we'll go ahead and
get that build done.
There it is, it's been tagged
and ready to get pushed up
to the Container Registry,
so let's do that next.
So we'll clear the
screen, and we'll
issue the Docker push command.
And that will push it up to
Google Container Registry.
This is going to
take a few seconds,
so I'm going to fast
forward the video,
and rejoin you when it's done.
As that gets pushed to
your Container Registry,
the next thing to do is
to actually deploy it
to our production cluster.
So I've got two clusters,
a processing cluster
and a production
cluster, and I'm
going to go into
Cloud Shell and I'm
going to log into my
production cluster.
And then, to make sure I
am on the right cluster,
I'm going to do a get
nodes, and make sure
that I see all the nodes of my
production cluster, which I do.
So now let's take a look
at our deployment yaml,
and you can see
nothing special here.
I'm deploying that
Container Registry image
that I pushed up earlier, and
so let's go ahead and do that.
kube ctl apply minus
F, symbol deployment
dot yaml will create my
kubernetes deployment.
So give that a minute
to settle down,
and then we'll check
the status here.
Clear the screen.
And let's check and see
if our pods are there.
And there's our pod.
Check our deployments.
And the deployment is there.
Now let's go ahead and
expose that deployment
behind a load balancer.
This will take a couple seconds.
I'm going to pause the
video and I'll rejoin you
when it's up and running.
All right, let's do a
kube ctl get services,
and that will list out the IP
address of our load balancer,
so we're going to
grab that IP address,
we're going to come up here
into Chrome and open a new tab,
paste in that address, click
there, paste the address in,
and that will open the
Cymbal University website.
So let's hit Enter.
There's the website.
Let's click Courses.
We're still connected
to our database,
and if I go back into
Google Cloud platform,
and I look at the
VM instance, I'll
see that it's still
stopped, meaning
that I am in fact serving
my application now
off of the kubernetes cluster,
out of that container.
So there you have it.
In this video, you learned
about using Migrate for Anthos
to move Windows workloads
into containers, including
how to assess your application,
create the migration plan,
execute the migration
plan, and deploy your newly
containerised application.
Be sure to like and
subscribe because we'll
be posting subsequent
videos in this series
to cover topics such
as best practices
for evaluating
your applications,
how to migrate Linux
workloads, and more.
And to get started on
Migrate for Anthos today,
visit
Cloud.Google.com/Migrate/Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]